I have run yeah can you hear me hello
yep right thanks Dave that was a very
nice intro and you better get some of
those tickets for FX cuz I really want
to see it now I'm gonna look a bit weird
I'm gonna be dual wielding clickers
that's not something to presentations
it's just we've got a few technical
problems so yeah it keeps my hands busy
and stops to doing silly things of them
so anyway right keeping it simple if CSS
it scales so it's just gonna work yeah
oh this isn't gonna wear the hold on
there we go right so CSS has a weird
place on the web today we've got some
polarization going on we've got a camp
that is CSS SERPs boo hiss and then
we've got CSS rules the comfort that I
like to live in and I empathize
naturally with that camp more but I'll
explain why because I have a theory why
the CSS sucks camp have the attitude
that they do and I think is a
combination of them over engineering the
CSS and not fully understanding the
power that the language gives them an
approach in it like it's a language like
JavaScript expecting it to work in the
same way so I'm going to do in this
session is going to tackle the first bit
and talk to you about how it can
simplify CSS to give us incredible power
while also being as low tech as possible
and the secret sauce for this session is
night we're going to talk about CSS well
I will do a little bit but you'll see so
let's talk about scale scale is bollocks
I absolutely hate it when we use the
term scale but we're sort of trapped -
they were trapped with words like scale
where we're trapped with words like
serverless and jam stack and the worst
one of all of them performant which
isn't even a real word but they do
provide a nice construct for
communication you can you know what
someone's going to be talking about when
they mention one of these words and that
makes sense in this talk - because you
knew you'd be follow up and listen
the job so I was going to be talking
about large projects large teams complex
code all that rubbish that we talked
about on Twitter and one thing I do get
really pissed off about with scale is it
gets slightly muddied when people use it
as an excuse to over engineer something
I'll take this example will you CSS in
J's library because our product needs to
scale and I with some Chad from the Bay
Area and it'll be and let's be [ __ ]
honest for a moment the furthest place
is shift is going to scale is right in
the bin so it's not a valid excuse is it
and there he is this is a chat and I'll
be bold and straight up and I say I
don't think using scales an excuse for
engineering stuff especially CSS is ever
acceptable even for huge teams that work
in huge projects then keep that in mind
because that's going to be the key theme
of this session along with swear words
and Chad's but we'll see how we're gone
so now breaking this the rest of session
into four key things and I think these
four key things are what can help you
achieve the sort of things I'm trying to
talk to you about today and you'll get a
little progress bar thing as well apply
this so you can see just how much longer
you've got to endure me for so here they
are don't panic communicate consistency
and simplification now I could package
this up as DCC s a mop up all those up
verts on that shitty orange website I'll
get a lot of retweets on Twitter but I'm
digressing let's actually talk about the
content so are you gonna go yeah
don't panic now one of my favorite books
is The Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
and it's about the earth being blown up
and to be made space for a hyperspace
highway and then you get our two main
characters with an hitchhike the way
through space and our main character
Arthur Dent on the right proceeds to
hitchhike with this power Ford Prefect
and I notice a drop
[ __ ] synopsis we didn't come here to
listen to me talk about The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy well are you gonna
be disappointed but anyway the actual
guide that the book is all written about
the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy is
sort of interactive encyclopedia well by
1979 standards anyway but the thing
about it is on the cover of the
encyclopedia it has these this dirt
panic ring on it and it really resonates
with me because the phrase is used so
many times throughout the story or the
TV series even when the context of the
situation very much cause for panic
and if I missile resonated with Ford
Prefect as well he's guiding after
Dennis bumbling brick through the
mind-boggling adventure in space and he
always approaches challenges with this
calm pragmatic attitude don't panic and
I said a takeaway for was to on the web
so when Arthur first gets the book he
says this he says I like the cover don't
panic it's the first helpful or
intelligible thing anybody said to me
out there take whatever metaphor you
want from that but anyway now I can see
out there in the audience you're all
looking at me going what the [ __ ] is he
on about
this isn't about CSS so I'll try a move
on this in CSS so don't panic is good
advice because when we panic we do silly
things so how many think about how many
times you've made horrendous CSS
decisions because you're up against a
deadline and a project that's got it's
under budget are some business if I put
your hands up who's that important in
CSS before Wow pretty much the whole
room that's fine and it is fine we can
do that but what isn't fine is technical
debt and often panic goes beyond a
little hack here and there and then it
escalates into something much more
serious like employing a CSS nsj
framework which is like paying off your
house mortgage with a one gallon
incredibly high interest technical debt
which foster a lien Lee the developer
who took out that technical debt doesn't
have to pay it back because anomaly piss
off and go and work somewhere else after
year and it's the user who has to use
that site who has to pair that technical
debt for them as Bruce explained in his
talk you know people in countries have
to pay an absolute fortune in comparison
to their salary in order to look our
[ __ ] websites and this boggles my mind
when you consider what we have available
to us in CSS so I was going to digress a
little bit and talk about the current
state of CSS because I don't think we
talked about this enough about what we
have available to us and how it compares
to what we've had previously so I've got
bar chart I like about John we've never
had it better with CSS layout so look at
this here we've got display of August
let's display a grid grid is coming in a
93 percent complete support 98.8% and
then obviously block 200% so you can see
blockin grid and flex are almost
identical to each other so if you use
these tools with the progressive
enhancement mindset you layout is just
sorted job done no worries so move on
and have a look at the other thing that
I think it gives us great power in CSS
is CSS custom properties and their
native CSS variables incredibly handy
for tokenizing our CSS so in this
example here I'm setting a primary color
I mean I've got myself a box and a badge
and I'm setting the background and the
color respectively
I'd end it with this which is pretty
cool and because they're affected by the
Cascade as well we can override them
contextually so I've got this little
snippet here so I've got a little about
page class and on my about page I want
to make them hot pink obviously this is
the only color slide you're gonna see
for the entire presentation and there
they go and these are just a subset of
the powerful new features but you can
start to see how modern CSS is
incredibly powerful and effective style
until we've niggled the way at the edges
and the heart
have to do in the past and now we don't
really have an excuses but CSS can get
out of hand still especially you've got
to write lots of CSS so how do we may
get that and this is why I'm a huge fan
of sass because all that narrative
functionality is cool isn't it
you know we've got all these cool things
that CSS give us but let's not forget
about Ned nesting too which is another
one of these cool things but who has to
do all the work when we use native CSS
nesting
it's the browser class to do all the
work for us rather than a precompilation
tool like sus and in most cases that's
absolutely fine although thought of
native CSS nesting terrifies me
especially when we're already closing
the browser was a shitty JavaScript
heads the metaphor image we don't have
to abandon sucks because native language
features are coming too it's probably
better to cautiously pre-compile your
CSS and not a faster browser to work as
hard it's already working hard enough
re rendering the Dom every time one
piece of data changing is there so why
make it work harder just so you can have
nested in their native nesting to me it
smells like developer experience of a
user experience and a god Bruce touched
on this as well in his talk because we
throw stuff in the bin without thinking
about all the wider implications of it
so yes we'll get nesting soon but how is
a lower powered device like this going
to handle five levels of nesting which
air selectors how is that same lower
powered device going to handle
calculating the color of a custom
property that's been overridden by the
Cascade five times it doesn't matter how
good the native tools are because if it
keeps throwing [ __ ] code that browsers
the users will suffer for it and just
that of them just for cure so this is a
Motorola MOTO C plus which is less than
a hundred pounds Android smartphone
which makes the vast majority of Android
usage so just remember that in fact
global mobile usage is powered by the
sort thing lower powered devices
remember that when you you know building
your crap so anyway
sass the beauty of sass is you can have
the best of both worlds which I like I
like a happy meeting rather you get your
cool stuff like your nesting but if you
do it right you get nice flat selectors
which we'll come to as well you also get
components if you want by using partials
and you can set your project up to get
multiple bundles you can also link your
CSS at Build time so you know when [ __ ]
is getting out of hand right in the
terminal or GUI and the most important
thing is that with sass well CSS SCSS
sorry you still writing CSS because s
CSS is smart enough to do just what it
needs to focus on and leave the rest of
your CSS alone and to me that seems like
a pretty perfect setup
so communicate we've talked about dirt
panic and how we can mitigate panic and
make more sensible decisions so that's
it and don't worry we're not just a
quarter way through your place thinking
I can't wait for it to get off but we're
there so let's talk about communication
exactly this is really really important
because naming is hard and let's use the
context of generated CSS class names
because naming is only hard when you
don't talk to each other and do you know
how we get around naming collisions like
a human a little bit like this so I've
generated this pretend scenario so we've
got developer one licorice here and
she's found this very typical problem
where they try to create a new component
in CSS so this is them saying this
component that came up with our exists
let me have a quick looking kitten so
you created it ah it was Isabella so
this point some developers might have an
existential crisis and start dreaming of
a machine generated class name so we
know how problematic there can be for
assistive technology
cough-cough Twitter but check this out
we're gonna try this novel thing called
talking to each other so uh look uh she
does this she goes to find Isabella she
says hey Isabella is there a reason why
this component is called block and then
as well as got an answer follows oh yeah
this very important reason
how about you call that component box
instead now let's break this response
down got two things there's an important
reason could be anything it could be a
stakeholder decision it could be a
legacy code base issue or it could just
be a design decision all of these things
can be immovable and that's fine and
then the most important thing is because
Isabella a professional who understands
how to communicate effectively helps it
to create a new component Liam instead
that's a good idea and imagine that what
happens when you actually [ __ ] talk
to each other is he you generate instead
of throwing tools at things to try and
fix a problem if you actually speak to
each other you might actually be able to
do it in person you know however email
or slack and so-called soft skills which
I prefer to call core skills are shunned
in favor of being able to build your own
linked list or fizzbuzz on a whiteboard
and that winds me up because to be an
effective member of a team you have to
be able to communicate whereas the only
time you ever build that linked list
from scratch than that stupid interview
that you had to go through and this
slightly goes against what Sally said in
their talk but it's still important to
say is that document everything because
another incredible way of communicating
that's not actually talking to each
other is right in and I can see a few
people perk up like ah yeah I'm not
talking and that's it and I love writing
he might have noticed if you read my
blog I write a lot of stuff and I do a
lot of it because I like to write things
down because I never know when I'm gonna
need them and it also helps me to commit
stuff to memory as well as when I learn
things that I write about it it sticks
in my brain bear and another thing
that's really cool is if you know a
large team of front-end developers write
CSS or any code really you can document
your thought process and also document
contexts and this is a great example
from the bulld design system where at
the bottom of the component they've got
this research insight that gives the
developer a bit of context about why
they've made cent decisions about the
buttons which is really useful this
great quote by our who was running the
design team at the time and you should
follow our she use incredible
what she does in the design system
community she says one of my favorite
details in bulb energies new pattern
library research insights that explain
rationale behind some of the patterns
based on user research it's just so good
and it's so so useful so by
documentation I don't mean that you need
to write Williams in means obstructed
docks - I'm talking artist rights and
bloody comments in ecard
simple things take this example if I
understand didn't listen someone else's
code base okay why what the [ __ ] is
going on here
they've set a CSS class with an
important on a color property what what
why they even done that and should you
buys the reaction then we've all been
there we've all done it but then check
this different example out if I landed
on this I'll be more like our fair
enough there's some context here and
what I was saying here is that there's
the cavities in the legacy apps is
occlusion between existing styles so
fortunately they have to go nuclear
it's certainly a refactor target I might
think are cool a bit a spare time to
their so I might have to try to fix that
specific issue for them and notice I can
actually sell that word something larger
so good written communication can
prevent unnecessary collisions between
people which can in turn prevent
expensive tech deck crate by tools in
our lives of win-win in my books so
let's move on consistency enough of me
yammering about how to be a functional
adult for a minute because of this far
into the talk I'm not even told the
authorized CSS yet so let's do a bit of
that because I think consistency is key
to scaling CSS sorry I said scale again
really this is what these other
abstractions are trying to do but they
just go a bit too far so now for clients
I use this methodology it's called sea
view and it stands for a cascade block
element utility talking and I'll explain
what each one of those means but
obviously I need to tackle this that CPU
is proper [ __ ] there in front of whether
it suits the rest of the couple of the
core move for names for projects doesn't
it so it sits in fine so the see in CSS
stands for cascading
and those in love a little side project
well I think that I do often go against
the grain on what the C and CSS stands
for cascading is easily one of my
favorite parts of CSS I think it's what
gives it a great power their house so
with this methodology that I've got C
view I set things as high as possible or
set everything like Carl as high as
possible
I want everything to cascade down into
the component so here I'm setting just
basic font and color but then when I use
a real bone not up tentative a real one
I can this use font in Harry and Lily
it'll inherit all the typography of a
button and then a pull current color the
alias keyword and it'll find what the
contextual color is and use it in the
button and it means I can write really
skeletal CSS components they're hinting
that the browser rather than forcing it
to do what we want them to do because
that's how we generate ship websites so
then we want to block now block is your
component it's your card or your button
and it's the building block of your user
interface and really the way I use
blocks is it's a construct it's a
wrapper it's a container I don't tend to
write much CSS in a block itself I tend
to save that for the elements themselves
and these are dependents of my block and
you can see that by the way that the CSS
selector is structured you've got card
to underscores and then image and the
same with body now this is I've ripped
the strap em because this is one thing I
love about them is that you can read CSS
and the HTML and see what belongs to
what or what the relationship is and I
think that's really useful not just for
any developer but for junior developers
you've never worked on the curb rate so
far because they can see things a lot
clearer just by the way it was structure
in our selectors so then inside the
actual element themselves I tried to
keep the CSS inside them as light and
global as possible so in the card body I
don't really care about what's in the
card I don't want to count I want to
support anything that happens to fall in
there so what I do is he is just
lobotomize the whole selector
and I add one rem-pod
air margin on top of sibling elements as
you can see on the diagram now it's only
adding it to the paragraph and the burn
which is a really handy way of just
supporting any content in there it's
great so we move on to utility and this
is a class that does one job and it does
that job well I feel like a plumber or a
tin-opener
an example of a utility class is one
that sent this text or makes it bold
it's a simple low fidelity tool
importantly it means that you can write
comments CSS and apply it wherever you
need it rather than repeating yourself
over and over again
and then we want to talk him and this is
actually still a utility class but in
the context I work in is to generate
utility class that's generated from high
level design tokens and I can see one or
two you think in what the [ __ ] is a
design token well I'll let my pal Jeana
explain what they are because she
invented them and design tokens are the
visual items of the design system
specifically they're named entities
solve visual design attributes we can
use them in place of hard-coded values
in order to maintain a scaleable and
consistent visual system we've got
design tokens that live separate from
the code that you're writing and it
means that those same design circuits
could power print or native app or any
other different things that your design
system powers and that's how we're using
them here so in the context of this card
I'm using two different design tokens
I'm using one that says use the brand
font which is that nice heavy font there
and I'm saying then make the size of the
text 600 and then what that 600
represents is a part of the sizing scale
that I use too so I'm using and this is
an example of my website I've got a
style guide on there and I'm using the
major third sizes go and you can see you
got that lovely curve between sizes and
then I use our sizing scale for
everything else too so don't just use it
for sizing my text I use it for spacing
elements and usually even just for
adding padding inside elements I use our
social scale and you see it's love
rhythm and flow between all of your
elements on the page and that's it
that's the methodology that I use these
days and I'm not going to stand here and
say this is the best way to write CSS
because it actually probably isn't but
what it is then this is the important
things it's consistent just like Ben or
H CSS or some axes all these different
methodologies so find something that
works for your team stick to it and
document the hell out of it
enable people in your team to make
consistent decisions without slowing
them down
one thing I'll say about methodologies
is that we find yourself restricted by
one invest time into experimenting with
something different things change so
embrace that as much as you can and this
is why I now use the C Butte methodology
rather than Ben which I use these
I think bones [ __ ] amazing but I also
run into issues where modifiers were
getting out of hand so I have to sit
back and a simplified last trial achieve
with modifiers and I settled on using
utilities and tokens because that was
the sort of thing I was affecting with
modifiers so always be open to change we
live in dynamic world and we work in
incredibly dynamic industry we stick to
guns too tightly you're probably going
to end up causing more problems not just
for yourself but for everyone else in
the future too so it would be pretty
wild if I did a talk that the word
simplifying it and did talk about
simplification on there so let's talk
about that now and the thing I love to
talk about the most that's talked about
frameworks for a minute do you really
need one in the modern web Casa del Sol
bootstrap is an incredibly powerful
framework though and it came at a time
when we were learning how to build
responsive websites and were fighting
relentless compatibility with browsers
as well is literally the worst time to
do front-end development because we had
iu6
and responsive web design at one point
which is just health sir bootstrap
helped make that easier for us and I'll
even go as far as saying but by accident
bootstrap is one of the best design
systems that's ever been created because
it powered so much
the web at one time where you could
actually smell a bootstrap site just by
London on it you know they all had a
whiff about them didn't there that's
probably CPU burning up trying to render
the CSS but anyway I digress using
bootstrap today when we have actual
native tools to do the job that it does
like grid and flex he's like using a
sledgehammer to crack an egg it can also
bring complications of its own just like
other frameworks here because I will
just single out bootstrap because of the
way these are built they use very global
selectors and aggressively style
elements so then we end up with these
situations again where people are making
bad decisions all hacking to make their
project workers is because people don't
change the defaults as always this thing
where people say oh yeah but people
don't just use the default bootstrap the
majority people actually do use the
default chart and the same goes for
tailwind CSS - which just gives me a
heart attack every time I see this is
they use generates over 40,000 lines of
CSS by default when you pull the
distribution build out and I build stuff
that's been 120 sites across 20
different languages that had even a
fraction of that CSS isn't inexcusable
to generate that much CSS by default so
what I'm saying really is if you have a
solid methodology like BEM its CSS max
or even sea view you could sprinkle a
bit of grid system with you know grid
out some layer helpers or flex and you
are golden and this is the sort of
methodology that we're trying to do with
every layout which is a book that Acco
offered with my good pal head and high
head in here I'm oh yeah good sir for
layouts we find the most robust solution
by simplifying and distilling the
problem as much as you can then we use
hints in rules axioms mister fell out to
not to micromanage the browser but
instead we saw say yeah do this but you
know what if you don't do that's all
good do that instead we try to keep
everything as simple as possible and
what this does is we achieve these
really solid
Brazilian future-proof layouts and it
seems be coming down pretty well and
what we're doing today because we're all
friends here we've done a discount cos
if you actually want to go out and buy
it today if you use discount code s OTB
he's getting a swipe set off but we do
really appreciate the support we've been
getting for it so far it's been pretty
amazing so let's talk about one of my
favorite subjects progressive
enhancement now I want you all to gather
round and take a knee for a moment don't
dismiss modern CSS because you have to
support ie 11 now [ __ ] hear this when
you get someone on Twitter will share
something really cool and then you'll
get this guy turn up in their things and
they'll be like what about only 11
though
stop trying to pixel [ __ ] he designs and
instead use progressive enhancement to
create a sensible default that
automatically improves our supplies
available uncle Bruce has been through
that with us this morning little
illustrated it perfectly when his site
rendered beautifully in the first-ever
browser we should be using that
methodology and targeting the least
powerful devices and then enhancing the
experience where the support is
available so take this example with a
grid we've got a good ol three column
grid here and in times gone by would
employ some hacks not just a layout but
to also make it look like this in every
single browser so what I propose is we
take a step back and simplify the
problem to find a sensible baseline and
this way I think this is sent to a
baseline good old stuck in with space
you know just like browsers are supposed
to do and we can achieve a hundred
percent coverage with a tiny amount of
CSS and this is the CSS to the powers it
so first and you can see a little code
pen up there as well so you can have a
look at this and after it I will put the
slides up as well so this little auto
grid here uses autofill a min/max to
just generate a grid of no media queries
whatsoever that's it that's the only CSS
you write and you get that whole
responsive grid whether we know our CSS
grid isn't quite fully supported yet so
what we do is we have this little bit of
CSS too and what we're doing is we're
targeting elements inside the our grid
class and we're saying just give it a
max width of 25 room and then push it
into the middle with my auto margin
and then while using that girl's
lobotomized our selector again and I'm
saying this had a bit of top space
between elements and that'll do for the
old crusty browsers happy days and then
where grid is supplied we can use CSS
are suppose to detect that as well we
can just unset some of these rules so
we've got this great keyword called
unset which will just remove the max
width from the browser for us and then
we just set the margin back to zero and
because browsers are support grid
support supports the salaah supports we
can we can sit on this and it's fine and
if it breaks because a CSS the way it
works it was carry on doing its job it's
fine because we've got that sensible
default or soon did drastically go wrong
it's all good
and that's 22 lines of CSS no hacks and
it works all the way back to IE 9 and
that it is a 99 in browser stack just
sitting there backing away living its
best life so the last point on
simplification and really this is the
last point of today's talk before I wrap
up and that is slow down seriously
slow down I know it's hard when you're
working on a big project when you're
working sprint to sprint but trust me
when [ __ ] hits the fan
slow down I came a cropper to this
earlier in the year when I was working
on a big pattern library design system
and we suffered some complications of
the client really earlier in the project
and what I did is I just kept plowing on
a write and CSS I'm not really thinking
about what I was doing and what sure
they're doing this was just stopped
step back and put some critical thinking
in place and I'd have saved myself so
much hassle by doing that because what I
ended up with was two or three [ __ ]
grid systems some fluid type doing one
thing some utility driven time doing
another thing and a card compound and it
was pretty much a whole website in
itself and it was an absolutely travesty
and I would say myself all our stress he
would just slow down thought about it
methodically and count with bare
solutions so I'll just leave you with
this today instead of moving fast and
breaking things move slowly and deliver
instead and with that thank you very
much for your time
[Applause]
[Applause]